as chief economist at a major
international consulting firm John
Perkins advised the World Bank the
United Nations the International
Monetary Fund the US Treasury Department
fortune 500 corporations had leaders of
countries in Africa Asia Latin America
the Middle East his groundbreaking
expose the confessions of an economic
hitman spent an astonishing 73 weeks on
the New York Times bestsellers list
since then his books on economics
geopolitics and indigenous cultures have
sold more than 1 million copies he is
also a founder and board member of the
nonprofit's dream change and the
Pachamama Alliance would you please give
a big round of applause and help us
welcome John Perkins
[Applause]
thank you thanks clay and thanks present
in this amazing independent bookstore a
round of applause for this bookstore in
love is independent bookstores thank you
thank you all for being here tonight
it's a it's a great pleasure to be here
with you I think well I wanted to
actually share a st. Patrick's Day story
with you happy st. Patrick's Day so a
couple of years ago I was in Washington
DC and I was at a dinner with a bunch of
people from the State Department very
high level people at the State
Department and I was actually in
Washington to speak at the Green
Festival and somebody's mentioned to one
of these high-level people from the
State Department that I was there to
speak at the Green Festival and he he
says oh my gosh he looks at those
watching he says but it's not st.
Patrick's Day yet that's that's the
State Department for you
Green is Irish time or money so I think
my being here begs the question why
would I write a new confessions of an
economic hitman 12 years after the other
confessions of an economic hitman the
original was written and there's really
two parts to that answer to that
question one is that things have changed
so radically since then the whole
economic hitman system then I described
in my book has had taking place in the
developing countries has now like a
cancer metastasized and spread to the
United States Europe and the rest of the
world and the second part of the
question is that people around the
planet have become aware of this we're
waking up there's a consciousness
revolution people everywhere are
understanding that the systems of
failure and that we live on a very tiny
space station without any shuttles we
can
get off we're gonna have to fix it we're
gonna have to take care of it
and I think this also then to realize
where we are today begs for questions
one is how did we get to this situation
that we're in today a space station
that's on the verge of crashing into
what drives this system free do we have
any reason to hope we can really change
it and for if we have reason to hope
what do we do to change it and so I'd
like to answer those questions tonight I
don't want to start by saying yes we
have tremendous hope I have tremendous
nope I know that we're winning this
revolution this battle this war this
this this movement we're winning it and
we're going to continue to win it and
we're going to move forward and we're
gonna create something marvelous but
let's go back and take a look at this
first question how did we get here and I
think I'm in a rather unique position to
describe that because I was in the front
lines of creating some of the problems
there's an economic hitman my official
title was chief economist as clay
mentioned that at a consulting firm in
Boston well my real job was to identify
countries with resources that our
corporations covet like oil and then
arrange a huge loan to that country from
the World Bank or one of its sister
organizations however the money didn't
go to the country it went to our own
corporations like one not too far from
here Bechtel and number of others who
made huge profits off these deals and
built big infrastructure projects like
power systems and industrial parks
highways ports airports things that
would benefit a few wealthy families in
these countries the ones who owned the
industries and the commercial
establishments but didn't help the
majority of the people in fact the
majority of people suffered tremendously
because money was diverted from paying
for health care education and other
social services to go toward trying to
pay the interest on the loan in the end
the principal was never paid
and so we'd go back to the country and
say since you can't pay your debt sell
your resource oil or whatever real cheap
to our corporations without any social
regulations or environmental
restrictions or privatize sell your
utilities sell your water and sewage
system sell your bank sell your schools
sell your prisons to our corporations
hmm and in the few cases where we failed
the Jackals would go in and these are
people that either overthrow governments
or assassinate their leaders I talked in
the new confessions of an economic
hitman about how two of my clients who
actually became good friends jaime
roldos the democratically elected
president of ecuador and omar torrijos
the head of state of panama they were
had tremendous integrity they didn't buy
into my deals I couldn't convince them
and they were both assassinated by CIA
assets and so in this way oh and I just
also mentioned that when the Jackals
also failed as it was Saddam Hussein and
Gaddafi of Libya who had very good
security forces were hard to get at they
had look-alike doubles when the Jackals
also failed then the military would go
in so in this way we created really the
world's first truly global Empire it's
not an American Empire it's a corporate
empire and its global it's the first
global one and it's become even more
prevalent since those days so I would
just like to share with you a little
story to get a little bit more detail
about that using jaime roldos as an
example in ecuador I'd been a Peace
Corps volunteer in Ecuador from 1968 to
71 and then I became chief economist
economic hitman and I was sent back to
Ecuador there was a military junta in
charge and they were our puppets we
control them the oil companies were
making huge progress in the Amazon
destroying the Ecuadorian Amazon
a lot of you know the Texaco chevron
story that punch oh mama Alliance is
about how many of you know of Pachamama
Alliance all right you know I'm the
co-founder with Bill and then twist and
if you don't know go to Pachamama org or
john perkins organ i'll take you there
but so party mom Alliance is working on
correcting a lot of the mistakes that
were made during that time the military
hooda was supporting the oil companies
and eventually in the late 70s a
decision was made to have democratic
elections it's a long story
the details are in the new confessions
of an economic hitman is how that came
about but to make the long story short
jaime roldos was elected president he
ran on a platform that said Ecuadorean
the revenues from ecuadorian oil are
going to help the Ecuadorian people
Texaco and the other oil companies are
going to pay a fair share of their
profits to the Ecuadorian people so as
soon as he won the election I was sent
down along with other economic hitmen to
convince him not to fulfill his campaign
promises to convince him by getting him
to take large loans that would make his
family and friends very wealthy because
these projects do that for the people in
control
Jaime refused he had tremendous
integrity and no matter what I did he
wouldn't go along with it I'm trying to
do the same thing with Omar Torrijos in
Panama and he also refused and yet these
men both knew that Salvador Allende had
been taken out by the CIA in Chile and
not in Arbenz in Guatemala Mossadegh in
Iran
Lumumba in the Congo diem in Vietnam
they were very familiar with these
stories and I would tell them these
stories listen you can play the game and
get rich I got in this pocket over here
I get a couple of hundred million
dollars for you and your family this is
a metaphor but basically if you don't
play the game in this pocket
the Jackals are right behind me
I didn't actually carry a gun but they
did but nonetheless jaime roldos had
tremendous integrity
and died in an airplane crash in May of
1981 there's no question that it was a
rigged plane for hash Omar Torrijos got
his family together right after that and
he said my brother Jaime has been
assassinated and I'm probably next but
don't worry too much about me because
I've accomplished what I most important
thing I came here to accomplish I've
signed the canal treaty with Jimmy
Carter the Panama Canal is going to be
in the hands of the Panamanian people
that's what I wanted to see happen less
than three months later this exact same
thing happened to him as roldo so it was
almost the same plane Twin Otter there
was it crashed with him aboard killing
him and you know in in more recent times
we've seen just in 2009 something very
similar happened to the president of
Honduras President Zelaya
who tried to raise the minimum wage of
Honduras by 60% and big corporations
like Chiquita and old and other global
corporations US corporations objected to
this the economic hitman went to
Honduras in 2000 I tried to get this
zalaya to come around he wouldn't so he
was taken out of the coup he was not
assassinate take it out of the coup and
I think we all know now what's happened
to Honduras we were just in the last two
weeks we've seen two very very important
environmental activists assassinated in
Honduras in the three years after zalaya
was taken out a hundred and one
environment last activists were
assassinated in Honduras it's now the
most dangerous country in the hemisphere
maybe in the world these are the things
that happened and today we have another
whole set of economic hitmen who've come
to the United States as I said earlier
these are Wall Street moguls bankers
they have the names that they go by the
names of consultant political advisor
and
dard the vulture capital fun people the
the managers of these vulture capital
funds like the ones that just settled a
deal with Argentina for Argentina to pay
them almost five billion dollars these
are modern form of economic hitmen this
is what's happened to the system this is
what's brought us to here and I go into
great detail in the book about all of
these different forms of the new
economic hitman that have come along but
I just share a couple of things with you
I met with a bank senior bank
vice-president from Chase Bank not too
long ago it's in the book the detail but
the short version is that he explained
to me he said you know back a few years
ago we bankers had we had a lot of
integrity if you came to me and asked me
for a $500,000 loan and that for your
house or how she wanted to buy I
probably try to convince you to buy a
$300,000 house because I didn't want to
foreclose but after 9/11 which was
really the cutoff date after 9/11 we all
got together and kind of decided no
instead we're going to tell you go ahead
and take out a $700,000 loan you may
have to tighten your belt a little bit
but in the end you'll be able to get
twice that for it in a few years and of
course then the market crashes the
person loses a house the bank tandra
packages it and sells it to some
developer makes a double profit off of
it and this banker from Chase was very
frank about this this is what's been
happening in this industry we've seen
our bankers fail as people that we were
taught brought up all our lives to trust
to failed us our politicians you know
every politician out there just about
accepts a lot of money from big
corporations for campaign their campaign
financing and they also are told that if
they don't get elected or if they sought
decide not to run next time they'll have
very lucrative consulting jobs one
example out of many Christopher Dodd
Chris Dodd of Connecticut was Senator
for about 20 years the highly respected
he was chairman of the Senate Banking
Committee and when he ran for president
the financial services industry gave him
huge amounts of donations for his
campaign the very people that he was
watchdogging
that's extreme corruption that's this
modern form of economic hitman and I
don't have time to go into any more
detail on that but there's a lot in the
book about this whole new branch of
economic hitmen they use all the tools
that I use in the developing countries
but they're being used here debt student
debt credit card debt health care debt
you know that is slavery and it's being
used in such a big way so but I want to
move on to the second question what
drives this system well as I said
earlier this this new global Empire is a
corporate Empire and it's driven by one
goal to maximize profits regardless of
the social and environmental cost now
that's a new goal when the American
Revolution was actually fought not
against the king of England but against
the East India Company which controlled
the King of England what people don't
think that way very often but the East
India Company had controlled more than
half the world's trade in those days and
it basically wrote the laws for England
the king of England was part of that
organization and the East India Company
was extremely powerful and once the the
colonists won their freedom from England
the founders decided no corporation
should ever have that kind of power
again imagine that so the laws were
written across the land that no
corporation in the United States in any
state could get a charter unless it
guaranteed to serve a public interest
nothing about profits that was
maintained for over a hundred years and
charters lasted on average for ten years
and then the corporation had to go back
and demonstrate that it had served a
public interest and would continue to do
so that all ended in the late 1800s when
john d rockefeller convinced the state
of delaware to change that lie so my oil
companies can't can't work under that
kind of a perfect treatment you got to
change the law oh and if you do we'll
pay really good taxes and you
legislators can make a lot of money off
this deal and as we all know it's gotten
worse since then but when I was in
business school in the late 60s there
was still this concept of public public
interest public service I was taught in
business school that a good CEO makes a
decent rate of return for investors and
also serves the public interest
basically takes good care of his
employees takes good care of his
customers and pays taxes is a good
citizen imagine paying taxes I fear a
corporation pays taxes and also
contributes money to the education
system and recreational facilities that
all changed almost exactly 200 years to
the day after the original intent of the
public service thing was signed this is
all changed in 1976 when Milton Friedman
won the Nobel Prize in Economics by
stating amongst other things and
probably the most important thing he
said was the only responsibility of
business is to maximize profits
regardless of the social and
environmental cost and businesses have
bought into that ever since it's it's
given license to CEOs in fact some would
say a mandate to CEOs to do whatever it
takes to maximize profits including
corrupting the system the government
system and yet it's a relatively new
concept just in 76 and when Milton
Friedman came up with that concept we
had we everyone believed we had a
shortage of capital and an abundance of
nature we had plenty of resources that
was the belief in 76 minute you can
remember that I'm sure and that the
earth would absorb whatever trash we
threw at her you know the air the water
the earth nobody was talking about peak
oil nobody was talking about climate
change in those days so maybe Friedman
had something going for him at that time
but what we know now is things have
changed radically and so what drives
this system to
this concept of maximizing profits
regardless of social and environmental
cost is no longer valid
we can't live with it any longer can we
can you live with it any longer no we're
gonna change it aren't we yes so that
takes us to the next question where do
we get hope is the hope for change and I
just want to say that throughout history
human beings have gone through extremely
difficult circumstances I think about my
great grandmother who figured the United
States was was ending with the Civil War
and my grandmother who thought the world
was going to be over with World War one
and then the depression and then there
was world war two and then there was
Stalinism and we've gone through so many
times in history but always we human
beings have come together we brought our
resources in our communities together
and we've created change and one of the
ways that we've done that is by
understanding that there's two realities
there's the objective reality this
microphone and then that's the perceived
reality which is what I'm speaking
through these microphones and a
perceived reality is what really drives
human societies it's it there's no such
thing as a corporation except as we
perceive of it and then codify it into
law there's no such thing as a country
until we'd receive a borders and codify
them into law there's no such thing as
an economy until we perceive of it the
perceived reality and that's what's
driven cultures and that's where our
hope for change comes in I'm struck by
how in 1773 1773 the perceived reality
was that the British Empire was
invincible the strongest Empire in the
history of the world there's no way a
bunch of farmers and hunters and
fishermen could possibly stand up
against it and then George Washington
stood up before the Continental Congress
and he remembered 12 years earlier a
long time between my books how he'd
fought in the French and Indian War at
the Battle of the Monongahela and he'd
seen 1400 British soldiers completely
defeated by three
hundred Indians the British lost a
thousand men in that battle the Indians
lost less than 100 the British Jeff of
Braddock himself died in that battle and
Washington had witnessed it he went to
the Continental Congress and he said all
we got to do is stand behind trees
they're wearing redcoats and they're
just standing out there in a line
waiting to be shot and then Tom Paine
and Thomas Jefferson and others wrote
amazing pamphlets to empower the people
whose fires in less than a year the
perceived reality went from they can't
be defeated - we got up that's where
we're at today so there's hope yes is
there hope my god there's so much hope
we've changed so many things throughout
history you know you just look at when I
was in in college there was apartheid in
South Africa we convinced corporations
just a few of us convinced corporations
it only takes the critical mass to
convince corporations to stop supporting
a part-time it ended the river the
Charles River in Boston where I went to
school Rita was so polluted rivers in
Ohio are on fire with pollution we got
the corporations to clean them up to
open their doors wider to minorities and
women and more and recently that's
completely changed everybody's attitude
toward gender to label food we've got
GMOs yep oh we've got calories and
nutrition and fat and all that stuff
being labeled we've gone from 10 years
ago a country that had almost no solar
or wind power the one that now has
tremendous amounts of that the growth in
wind powers the curve like that all the
renewables meanwhile coal production
coal-fired plants that just they'd end
it basically there's still a few out
there but there aren't anymore being
built we've made huge changes we can do
it you can do it so now we have to move
into an era where we're really looking
at what's the how do we change the
driving force so this brings us to the
next question what do we do how do we
change this and the real answer is all
we got to do is what the American
colonists did change that perception
overnight and like the American
colonists the answer the question of who
can do it is you us we the people
our president whoever the next president
is is not going to do it our president
let's face it symbolically is important
that has very limited powers as to all
of our leaders
the corporations that control Washington
even if we elect a president let's say
Sanders gets elected and let's say he is
an acceptable penny from a corporation
he's still going to be surrounded by
politicians and lobbyists who have
accepted a lot of money from
corporations and also who have been
promised consulting jobs when they get
out of whatever they're doing is elected
officials so we know that the system is
stacked against them I'm getting some
sort of feedback here you've set a
problem okay good so many problem for me
so it's always been that we the people
have to do it
who is that way during the American
Revolution it was that way during the
wars it was that way during the
Depression it's that way now the circus
of the presidential elections and god
bless all those people that are pouring
their hearts out to run but it's a
devote it's a diversion in a way we want
to think that if only our person gets
elected everything will change but we
know in our hearts don't wait that it
won't we've got to make it happen you
and I have to make it happen and how do
we do that well that's big reason why I
wrote the new concessions as an economic
hitman because there's a whole strategy
in there for how all of us can make this
happen there's actually this long list
and they
what students can do what retired people
can do what people b-team student and
retired to do what exactly this to do
what investors can do but the the main
part of this is to recognize that the
corporation's have the control the
driving force is this idea that they
have to maximize profits and that's what
we have to change we have to understand
that the corporation's depend on you to
buy their goods and services to invest
in them to work for them to support them
with your tax dollars and government
policies they are totally dependent on
us and I have to say that I spend a lot
of time I've been lecturing to recently
had lectured to a corporate summit of
over 4,000 CEOs and CFOs
and I before when I was asked to speak
to them I contacted the organizers and I
said wow this must be a mistake you must
have the wrong John Perkins no they said
if you're the one I wrote Confessions of
an economic hitman you're the guy we
want and I said but why and they said
because our executives are smart people
and they know the system isn't working
you know and they quote statistics
there's a lot of statistics but one of
the most important ones I think is that
less than 5% of us live in the United
States we consume almost 30% of the
world's resources that's not a model
China with 19 percent of the world's
population can't do it
India can't Brazil can't Russia can't
it's a failed system we need to
understand that we can't continue with
it we've got to change it and what it's
going to take is a new goal for
corporations instead of maximizing
profits let's say hey make a decent
return for your investors we need
investors for new technologies and serve
a public interest let's go back to the
wisdom of the founding fathers
our corporations need to serve us not
just a handful of wealthy people you and
me and we need to convince these
corporations to convert the deth economy
into a life economy a life economy is an
economy that's based on cleaning up
pollution regenerating devastated
environments and alleviating the causes
of desperation violence terrorism around
the world so imagine just imagine that
if our corporations the ones that are
building missiles tanks war equipment if
instead our tax dollars went to pay them
to figure out how to mine the plastic
that's in the oceans how to clean up all
that terrible oil that's devastated the
Ecuadorian Amazon and many parts of the
Middle East and in fact every gas
station that was ever built in this
country use that oil and imagine if we
were to invest in young people the
entrepreneurs to come along and create
new technologies for energy we've got
solar and wind but ten years from now
the solar and when we have today is
going to look archaic
hopefully then we come up with new forms
of energy that are even much better than
anything we've even conceived of today
and transportation and communications
banking and wholesale and retail trade
imagine if we convince the big
agribusinesses to instead of continuing
to poison the earth with chemicals they
really came up with methods for starving
people around the world to grow food
organically and efficiently to store it
and distribute it efficiently this is
reality this is the new perceived
reality we don't have to imagine these
things we can make them happen you ready
to do that this is an exciting time to
be alive and so creating a defecated
converting a death economy into a life
economy that's the challenge here and
every core
executive I know wants to see that
happen what I hear from corporate
executives is we want to be green we've
had kids we've got grandchildren but
they'll say I'm afraid that if I lose
half a percentage of market share my
stockholders the big the big boys will
fire me and replace me with someone who
only cares about market share so what
they want is for you all of us to go out
and demand that they change overload
them with emails tweets posts on
Facebook saying I love your product
they're not the bad guys with us I love
your product but I'm never gonna buy it
again until you pay your workers in
Indonesia a fair wage or clean up the
Amazon or whatever it is and get all
your friends and neighbors all your
social networking circles to send that
same email these executives want that
even the ones that are sociopaths they
if they hear this message they'll listen
because sociopaths are not about making
money they're about being successful and
if we define success not as maximizing
profit but instead serving a public
interest they'll do it and we do have to
pay a decent rate of return to the
investors who are going to create these
new technologies but just a decent rate
of return and so you know I just want to
leave you I'm going to open this to
questions and discussion in a minute but
I just want to leave you with this
incredible optimistic thought I mean I'm
so excited I know we're gonna do this
we're already doing it it's happening
around the world I travel all over since
confessions was published 12 years ago
I've been giving speeches all over the
world it's almost been non-stop I've
been on the road almost constantly
probably 80% of my life for the last 10
years I've been to China and then in the
former Soviet countries I've been
talking to the Russian people I've been
in the Middle East and and and
Europe and Latin America and all over
the United States and everywhere I go
people are waking up there was a
consciousness revolution just like you
there understanding that we live on a
very fragile Space Station that has no
shuttles my eight-year-old grandson
grant won't be able to get off maybe a
few people will go to Mars and never
come back and maybe a few will go to the
moon but most of us are stuck here we
want to be here don't we it's a
beautiful planet and this thing's
getting ready so you are the answer this
is the revolution and so just to get a
little bit more about what we all can do
like I said there's these lists in the
book and I'm going to mention a few
specific things in a minute but the most
important thing is to recognize we need
to change these corporations and every
one of you needs to follow your passion
because it's only passion that keeps us
going and I don't know what your passion
is but I know that each one of you has
passion I had a passion for writing
something focusing on writing earlier
tonight I was talking with a friend who
has a passion for designing houses
furniture cabinets and so forth they're
from a very environmental sustainable
standpoint if you're a carpenter that's
what you can do if you're a dentist when
you have your hands and your clients
mouth talk to them about creating a
better world
if you're a parent bring your kids up
that way we can all take different
routes different paths but let's all
head for that same destination of
creating an environmentally sustainable
socially just world a life economy
instead of a death economy I often think
again to the American Revolution how
lucky we are that George Washington did
not try to write pamphlets and Tom Paine
didn't try to lead armies Washington had
a passion for leading men and and Payton
had a passion for writing pamphlets
Martha Washington had a passion for
organizing women to make clothes for men
at the forefront and they each followed
their passion and they headed for the
same destination though getting out from
under the tyranny of the British East
India Company we can all take different
paths but let's head for the same
destination of getting out from under
the tyranny of a deaf economy each one
of us has a role to play in this and
again in the book there's a number of
recommendations and I would just mention
three of them just as sort of examples
I've already started on what I would ask
every one of you every one of you to
pick a corporation that you'd like to
see changed you'd probably think of a
lot of Walmart Chevron Monsanto Nike
take a corporation that you want to see
changed and dedicate yourself to sending
an email once a week to all your
contacts and writing this email to that
corporation saying Monsanto or whatever
it is we want you to change we're going
to help you survive into the next
century because we want you to change so
that's one thing you can do a second
thing you can do is think about the
candidate you're considering voting for
her or maybe decided to vote for
or what is that biggest issue that that
candidate has presented that appeals to
you make a commitment to follow through
on that issue regardless of who's in the
White House if your candidate makes it
make sure that candidate gets all your
support and encouragement and you force
that candidate to move forward with that
issue if your candidate doesn't get
elected you go for it anyway because the
power of the Internet the power of
social networking now is much more
powerful than the power of the Oval
Office and the third thing you can do is
support movements that you believe in
movement to amend the climate change the
antics that he gives climate change
movements support Pachamama alliance I
know a lot of you already are amazing
organization that actually supports the
climate change and the movement to amend
movements but get behind organizations
join like-minded people come together in
communities that's a really good way to
change this perceived reality but none
of us come together and bring that
energy together to make that happen you
have the power you have the power think
of a hero in your life think of someone
that you consider a hero I don't know
who that might be
I like to think of Rosa Parks when I was
a kid growing up in rural New Hampshire
I had no idea that African mayor
America's had to ride on the back of a
bus in parts of my country until Rosa
Parks showed me how many have ever heard
of Rosa Parks well who is Rosa Parks a
woman who wrote on the back of watch
from the back of the bus to the Father
she did a lot of other things but that
was the most significant things you can
do that and I had no idea that the DDT
my dad and I were spraying on the
mosquitos be in the on the swamp behind
our house in New Hampshire to kill
mosquitoes was also killing fish and
birds until Rachel Carson wrote the book
Silent Spring and taught us that and
also start a whole worldwide
environmental movement how many of you
ever heard of Rachel Carson who was
Rachel Carson a woman who zappy saw
behind the little desk in a tiny house
in Pennsylvania took out a scratch his
peepers a piece of scratch paper and a
pencil instead of writing a book having
no idea would ever be published much
less than we changed the world well I'm
on that subject this book the original
this book was rejected by 39 publishers
I got 39 rejection slips and then a very
brave publisher just down the street
from you here in Oakland berrett-koehler
published it courageous publisher but as
Steve Pierce auntie the founder and went
to the New York Times bestseller list
and stayed there for a long time and
then all the other publishers wanted to
buy the paperback rights stay with it
you know we have tremendous power and
how many of you ever heard of Jack
Woodberry or Richard Davis and mrs.
Schnee oh my goodness Wow California I
thought you guys were educated here well
missus well Richard and and Jack were my
high school English and history teachers
mrs. cher was my third-grade teacher and
without them I wouldn't be here because
they taught me the power of history to
change the written word to change
history the power of writing to change
history mrs. schneir taught me how to
deal with a bully when I was in third
grade there was a fifteen-year-old guy
in my class and he was mean he used to
push me around on the playground and I'd
go right into mrs. schneir but she
didn't know what to do because the law
was he had to stay in school until he
was 16 you kick him out for a week but
then he had to come back and he was
meaner than ever and so one time is I go
running up to her crying she said well
Johnny I'm afraid you're just gonna have
to take care of this yourself and I said
but he's big and she said well here's my
suggestion next time he pushes you you
just haul off and kick
in the shins run like hell I don't think
she is the h-word I did funny thing
happened he whimpered and then he became
my friend my Ally my protector
and I learned that to deal with a bully
you got to stand up to him
and this bully system that we've got
right now of maximizing profits
it's a predatory form of capitalism it's
bullying us isn't that and we got to
stand up to it and the way to stand up
to it is to convince these people that
we've got to turn this economy around
we've got to transform the deth economy
into a life economy we've got to change
that goal of maximizing profits into a
goal of serving us the public interest
you ready to do that you better be ready
so I just want to leave you with one
final quote it's a 200 year old quote
but I think it's very very relevant to
these times it's a quote that came out
of the beginning of the American
Revolution December 1776 Tom Paine wrote
these are the times that try men's souls
and then he went on to say if there must
be trouble let it be in my day then my
child may have peace and so I think
that's why we're all here today so that
many years from now when my
eight-year-old grandson is my age he and
all of his brothers and sisters of all
species around the world can look back
at this time and say thank God those
people came together in 2016 and they
all committed to taking care of the
trouble in their day so that my
generation can all live in peace and I
so look forward to doing this with you
and thank you so much for being here
with me it's such a great honor and
pleasure to be with you thank you so
much
[Applause]
so I think we can have a few questions
and clay has the microphone yeah
absolutely please raise your hands one
of us will come around with a microphone
please speak directly into the
microphone we do have some some kind
guests here tonight from c-span
so we'll start right here in the front
[Music]
thanks for coming out and I one thing
that you don't mention is all of this
corruption is centered around the world
reserve currency the US dollar and
putting people in debt you refer to that
as slavery and there are I mean one
thing that I am aware of is something
called Bitcoin and crypto currencies in
general and I think one of the most
important things that people can do to
subvert this power this arbitrary power
of the dollar system is to stop using to
whatever extent possible the the dollar
I mean just I just like to get your
feeling about that yeah the power of the
dollar is incredible
and you know one of the things I talk
about in the book is is how Qaddafi was
really taken down because he was trying
to create a new currency the gold diner
and have all the African nations and all
the Muslim nations sell oil for this
currency Saddam Hussein and tried to do
something similar several others the
mullahs in Iran they've all been taken
down and they've done this or threatened
with that and in just recently some of
the emails Hillary Clinton's emails have
come out that have really talked about
that the Edward Snowden revelations
about how that what a huge impact that
decision of Qaddafi had on taking
Qaddafi out and so yes the the the US
dollar needs to be the whole Federal
Reserve System is is terrible it is an
enslavement tool and we need to change
it and I think you know this is your
passion so here's a great thing for you
to go into I
I love that I think yeah let's make it
happen and it's gonna take a little work
to make it happen but let's take it
happenin and realize that you're up
against a tough system here but that
makes it even more fun the bigger the
challenge the better you know the big
the bigger they are the harder they fall
so go for it please absolutely I'm
totally behind you on that
thank you
yeah hi John so um one interesting thing
about corporations as is that it's
treated like people and there's a lot
there's a movement you know let's not
treat them like people but I read some
interesting economic analysis that was
actually saying well that'll just make
things worse
well one thing that I thought about a
lot is that there's the concept of
punitive damages which could be quite
brutal composit Tory damages you know
for the same type of thing but it's
something to avoid the same thing
happening again in another similar
situation and what if there was some
deal where you say okay corporations
will still let you beat people but we're
going to do this under a specific
circumstances that we now have this
thing called corporation damages right
and so if you're a corporation then it
would be ten fold compensatory damages
and so you built you build into the
economic capitalistic system all the
driving forces is very simple idea but I
was just wondering your thoughts on if
what if anything like that could get
drive thank you thank you well first of
all I think we absolutely need to change
the law so that corporations are not
treated less people and and one big
reason for that it's become very clear
in the in the recent banking scandals so
about half a dozen of the world's
biggest banks have recently admitted to
creating huge crimes rigging LIBOR
rigging the exchange rates ringing the
all the different systems have set
interest rates they've been doing this
for over 20 years and they've admitted
to creating - they've criminal
activities they've paid 25 billion
dollars in fines for criminal activities
and not one banker has been indicted why
because corporations are considered
individuals but I ask you do
corporations commit crimes no banks
don't commit crimes people in banks
commit crimes not one of them has been
indicted in fact they've most of them
gotten bonuses because that 25 billion
is
small percentage of the profits that
they were allowed to keep be by paying
the twenty five billion and so the
criminals have not only not been
indicted they've given themselves huge
raises and therefore we need to take
that personhood out of corporations I
believe completely there's no and and
the other thing in there we people what
do you pick what do you pay
what do you pay taxes on your income
right corporations pay it on their
profits I had a lot rather paid taxes on
my profits than my in deduct all my
expenses and then yeah right but it's
not quite that simple and you know we
just see this over and over and over
again the terrible abuse of the system
why should corporation why would even
consider and we know too that that whole
idea came out of out of a late
18-hundreds Supreme Court case where it
was actually just a note on the folder
it was not actually part of the decision
the corporation's have that status but
but then Citizens United strengthened it
and there's been a lot of strength in
you know it since we need to get that
out of there
corporations are not people they don't
go to jail you can't put a corporation
in jail so my answer is let's let's
change that system I think that's the
most important part of it thank you
let's take we can do a woman this time
okay well I'd like to wish you happy st.
Patrick's Day dreams but I talked to
your book for that seven years in
Ireland to students and they were all
really responded to it and could relate
it to the Irish situation but I wanted
to know what made you change and since
you've changed have you ever felt under
threat
hmm yeah and I talked about that in the
notebook quite significantly so yeah I
spent some time travelling around
Ireland to trying to convince the Irish
people to vote against paying their
debts on the referendum that they turned
that down but I'm not sure they did I've
heard since that maybe the the results
were rigged anyway so for ten years as I
was in that system more and more I began
to see how flawed it was when I first
went and I thought it was the right
thing to do because business schools
teach you they still do that the way to
help a poor country is to invest a lot
of money and infrastructure just what I
was doing and in fact the statistics
show that the economy does increase when
you do that but as I get into this more
and more what I saw is that the
statistics only represent the very
wealthy people you know right now we
know that the sixty-two people on this
planet individuals who have as much
wealth as half the world's population so
the statistics are very skewed to those
people as they are in the United States
today and the so the poor were getting
poorer the rich were getting richer and
yet the statistics were looking really
good but he began to see that and so I
understood that the system was a bad one
but you know I have to say I have to
confess that once I was in there and I
realized I shouldn't be I was kind of
trapped I was living a life that I'd
always wanted to live I grew up a son of
a fairly poor teacher in a very wealthy
prep school in New Hampshire surrounded
by boys with lots and lots of money
hearing about the incredible adventures
they had in Buenos Aires in Paris and
Tehran and many other places and now
suddenly I'm traveling to all those
places flying first-class eating in the
best restaurants wining and dining with
presidents and beautiful women and was
stuck I didn't want to hear the truth
and then I began to realize though I was
living on a lot of Valium and alcohol
they did well he wasn't all that happy
and then after ten years I was I took a
vacation in the Virgin Islands I rented
a small sailboat anchored at off st.
John Island and I rode the dinghy ashore
and I've climbed up this Hill to an old
sugarcane plantation up there it was
beautiful up there the bougainvillea is
just gorgeous and I'm looking out at the
Sun setting over the Caribbean it just
seemed totally idyllic and suddenly I
was struck by the fact that this
plantation had been built on the bones
of thousands of slaves and then I
thought about the whole hemisphere has
been built on the bones of millions of
slaves and then I had to admit that I
was a slaver different I wasn't dragging
anybody around in Chains but I was in
slaving people in debt and at that
moment I made the decision never to do
it again I went back and quipped but
then I started writing a book and I
wanted to be an expose that it's really
card that talked about a lot of these
things like contacted other people that
have been in that business and other
jackals and very soon I got phone calls
threatening my life and my infant
daughter's life and the same time I got
taken out to dinner by the CEO of the
major consulting firm that had been a
competitor of ours still a Webster and
he took me out to dinner he said you
know you got a great resume I've been
chief economist of his rival he said
we'd like to use it in proposals you
won't have to do any work for us
I don't want to write you a check
tomorrow for half a million dollars this
is 1984 half a million dollars worth a
lot of money back then just don't write
the book
so what would you do
my daughter's life's being threatened as
well as mine I took the money and in my
own defense I'd say I didn't I am fan C
mansion or fast car or something I
reinvested it in new career it went back
to the countries I'd screwed that's what
I started forming these nonprofits like
Pachamama Alliance I went back and and
worked with people that had screwed to
try to change things and I started
writing other books books about
shamanism about indigenous people
shape-shifting the world was as you
dream it and that was okay with stoner
Webster but it didn't write the book and
then at 9/11 after 9/11 I went to ground
zero and as I'm standing there looking
at that still smoldering
pit I just thought I had to write this
book but this time I wouldn't tell
anybody I write it completely in secret
and it would be a confession not an
expose and once I get it out I figured
it was my best insurance policy that any
good jackal would know that if they shot
me or killed me
it would I'd be a martyr or sell a lot
more books and already was selling
[Music]
however about five months after the book
came out it was in New York City
and I was supposed to speak to the
United Nations on a Tuesday Monday night
under braces I was taken to lunch by a
very strange freelance journalist and I
went into the restroom
I just flown up from Florida and when
the food was being served and a couple
hours later I lost 70% of the blood in
my body internal bleeding
I was rushed to Lenox Hill Hospital and
I didn't talk about this and to allow
I'm you know but it happened after the
first book was written there's a whole
chapter this this book devoted to the
details and to make a long story short
in the end I had 70% of my large
intestine removed and when I asked the
doctor if it could have been poisoning
he said yes it said he said something
like growing on glass that would never
show up and blood tests and so on but
would eat through you could have been he
didn't he didn't say it we didn't know
for sure but that really impacted me
however the book was already written and
I just a little bit more careful about
who I have lunch with thanks for asking
yeah it's those moments of perceived
reality the perceived reality changed in
both cases and all those cases that's
where we got to go
perceived reality thanks we're gonna
take one more and if I could remind you
please stay in your seats once we finish
this up tonight and here's our last
question hello good evening honey I was
wondering given over the last 15 years
as you mentioned there's really been a
shift in consciousness and awareness and
simultaneously this you know increase in
platforms for people to make their
voices heard such as Twitter and an
alternative media why is this you know
on the one hand is this awareness kind
of increasing and yet on the other hand
corporations seem to have more power
than ever before in our political system
and and when do you think there'll be a
tipping point at which the corporations
and institutions will feel so much
pressure from the people that there will
be a shift in how they are structured
yeah I think that the answer the first
question of why did whether they have
why are they taking so much more power
because they're scared they know this is
periods ending and they don't know what
to do about it
and so when you don't know what to do
about it you do what you can do most
easily and best and these are people who
run these cuts not the corporations that
people run the corporations and and so
what they're doing is try to do what
they do best you know by like digging in
harder and harder and harder you know
they're trying to get every bit of it
out there it's a little bit like a
football player at quarterback was
winning a game by 21 points doesn't
start handing the ball over to the
opposition he goes for the record you
know he wants to go for 50 points or
something that's this kind of the system
we have and when will it change it'll
changed right away it's changing but we
have to keep sending that message that
it isn't the number of touchdowns you
make it isn't the money you make that
counts you and I we all need to send a
new message out there let's face it
we've been sending a message that says I
want cheap
well I want good tennis shoes that are a
reasonable price of an expensive price
and if that means they have to be made
by slaves in Indonesia I'll just look
the other way
I want cheap petroleum for my car and if
that means destroying the Amazon
rainforest I'll just look the other way
we've sent that message and we need to
change we get to send a very very strong
message that we want a life economy we
want these corporations to be driven by
one goal and that is to serve us and
future generations to create a life
economy that serves us our children our
grandchildren future generations of all
species that's what we are going to
insist upon and when we insist upon it
strongly enough when will it happen once
we insist upon it strongly enough when
enough of us really determined really
commit as you're all doing tonight
really commit to creating this world
that my grandson is going to look back
on when he's my age in about 15 years
when he's my age he'll look back and say
thank God you made that happen and so
there's your passion too so take a lead
in this yeah and you know what this is
so much fun you know I mean so I
mentioned that when I was an economic
hitman I was living this life that I
thought was right but I was living off
valium and alcohol I was miserable I
don't travel first-class very often now
and the size travel so much that
sometimes the airline kicks me up to the
empty seat up there because they got a
lot of miles I don't stay in first-class
hotels I stay with friends that was even
better but anyway and I'm really happy I
mean this is this is fun nothing more
fun than this revolution I used to think
damn I wish I had been born in the 1700s
so I could have participated in the
American Revolution this is bigger much
bigger you know what if the colonists
had lost the American Revolution that
would have affected a few people
if we lose this revolution it's going to
be the end of human life as we know it
we must win it and it's fun to win we're
going to win it we have fun doing it
it's the most blessed thing you can
possibly do it's a lot bigger than the
American Revolution and it's a lot more
comfortable so are you guys going to win
it yes you bet you are thank you so much
it's so wonderful to be here with you
again
thank you